okay building machine learning
applications on production is heart it's
really tough especially if we want to
implement machine learning models
algorithms in real-world applications
the challenge we face is usually way
more than just the modeling way more
than just the algorithm and that's why
we built prediction IO an open-source
machine learning server the goal is to
help developers and data scientists to
build to make the process more fun to
make it much easier for you to build
reusable engines predictive engines so
before I go into the details of what's
news in prediction IO and introduce our
newly developed software design pattern
for building predictive engines I like
you asked one question the question is
why do we need a machine learning server
so just want to make sure you guys are
not sitting here listening to something
that you don't need look at the space of
the open source data science industry
during number of tools available
especially in the JVM domain we have
Apache spark Hadoop machine learning
libraries you have Apache mahout you
have ml leap
data storage the bunch of them right
like X base Cassandra's so how many of
you are actually using this tools right
now a lot of you and how many of you
finding of implementing some of these
technologies okay thanks and how many of
you have heard of them like heard of any
of these technologies great so we're
quite well-informed in the JVM open
source data data science technology
space basically and it's great because
building JVM or Java open source
technologies with your application
it's a great way to put it onto
production but what's missing what is
missing is really something that would
hole all this stuff spark and le hadoop
xbase all together to give your
production ready development platform so
that you can build reusable tools for
productions and you don't need to worry
about scalability you can spend your
time better to worry about the business
logics to understand your data and to
evaluate the results to make better
predictions right the analogy I always
use is when I'm building a web
application I don't want to build
everything from scratch I would like to
have a web framework that's what we were
trying to achieve right now and it's an
early stage project so I would love to
get your feedback afterwards so let me
use a very simple and classic example in
this case to show you how you can make
use of the machine learning software
design pattern to do your your
development work better the example is a
classic recommender system if you have
read any like machine learning tutorials
textbook or materials the first case is
always a recommender system recommending
products so you have a mobile
application and now you want to do some
prediction predict what products a user
would like to buy or would like and so
you need an algorithm and it's not
difficult to find an algorithm nowadays
there are two ways you can do it one is
you download a machine learning library
Apache mahout or Apache spark ml web
they have state-of-the-art collaborative
filtering algorithms content-based
algorithms a lot of algorithms you can
you can use right away as a developers
we don't need to build a new model for
the rest of us if we're data scientist
we can also build our own model like
with with tools with hardware spark so
assuming the model is built then we can
make prediction
so this is the case that we want to look
at tonight very quickly with sample code
let's say the traditional way of
building recommender system prototyping
what do we do we read data from a file
it can be a well it has to be a well
defined data formats file it can be a
text file it can be a file store in HDFS
or s3 and with an existing algorithm you
can easily just load the data into the
algorithm class or function and then
they will give you a predictive model
with the predictive model what can you
do you can look through all your users
now you've read the data you use an
algorithm trainer model and then with
the model you can make prediction you
load all the users into the model and
now you call a function say I want to
recommend five products to each user's
done machine learning is so easy like
now I have a recommended system but
what's the challenge getting good
results so there are a lot of tools on
the market that can help you get good
results and before you know where the
result is good or not one way you can do
is do an offline test with the with the
data set to see if their algorithm is
good but more importantly you want to
put the algorithm on production you
actually need to deploy it on production
right so beyond prototyping now what you
need to actually put algorithms out
maybe as a service so that you can
respond to that I mercury so I want to
recommend five products to user a I want
to recommend ten products to use it B
while she is in San Francisco I want to
recommend only one product to a user who
is maybe now in New York so it's not
something you want to loop through the
model and then catch all the results so
we want
to deploy the engines as a surface and
in the engines you might also want to
integrate a lot of business logic into
it like what if I'm building ecommerce
applications the products may go out of
inventory and I don't want you to
include the products that is not no
longer available in my recommended
results right and of course for all of
us here we know how to build this kind
of code but the question is where should
I put a code like should I build my own
infrastructure for things like Oh new
data comes in I need to rebuild a model
and then we refresh the model with no
downtime or like so if we if we have
built web applications or mobile
applications before the concept of
separation of concern is not new to us
like we want someone who take care of
the data source data loading we want
another person to take care of the
algorithm make sure is highly accurate
and how do we make sure it's highly
accurate we want another component that
do the evaluation and sometimes you
might want to swap out an evaluation
component to do another evaluation and
also that's the serving component you
can add different business logics into
it and again it might involve another
team or another person in your company
to do it so we really need something
that we can start off easily but at the
same time it can scale out as we need on
production so this is what we will build
with prediction i/o easily with the new
design pattern so we provide an event
server it's a server that you can
collect all kind of data and there's
engines underneath the SERP hosting at
the same time of the server an event
server so you store all your events or
you stream all your events into the
event server and then you can have
different engines like recommendation
engines classification engines user
churn prediction engines things like
that you can build multiple engines
under the event
server so your mobile application will
send data to the event server and you
deployed an event server in real time
the mobile application can send curie to
this event web service engine web
service with REST API or with one of our
many SDKs and then you can retrieve
prediction results by calling the
engine's service as well this is the
ideal model we want to build and this is
much more beautiful than like just a few
lines of code building it on prototype
right so let's talk about the event
server first because it's simple before
we jumped into amazing thing like how we
can actually build an engine event
server is something come out like it
within within the box of prediction IO
so you install brick Chennai oh there's
the event server the way you launch it
is just type Pio event server and then
you can collect data into it just by
it's just very similar to the way you
use other analytical tools like Google
Analytics Mixpanel
it's all events base in this case you're
sending the data user 1-2-3 is giving
the item of product 100 a rating of 5
and you can do all sorts of data
integration into it like you can update
the user attributes you can give a
description to a products and things
like that and many people would ask hey
I already have my database I have my
MongoDB I have my Hadoop
so what am I going to do here I'm going
to show you how we can modify the where
at least not showing you how but where
you can modify the place that you are
pulling data so if you don't like the
event server you can put data from your
existing data source but most of the
time we see cases where you would like
to have a separate event store for new
kind of machine learning development so
it's really up to you open source so
it's really flexible
now here we comes to the fun part I talk
about separation of concern I talk about
a new kind of software design pattern
where you can do something like MVC for
machine learning and this is exactly
where we'll use it we'll use this kind
of new technologies to build an engine
so we invent a new name called das EE
days sounds much better than MVC and we
see you can't pronounce it but days is a
name right so everyone can remember the
name days so days stand for very simple
components D data sauce data preparation
this is where you put data into an
engines and this is where you do data
cleansing so that the data format is
suitable for the algorithms that you're
going to use a obviously stand for
algorithms or algorithm depends if
you're building one algorithm in this
engine or a lot of data scientists would
like to combine multiple algorithms or
they want to evaluate different
algorithms to see which one works better
so this is the great framework for you
to work with more than one person or if
you're just trying to test our
out-of-the-box algorithms s is serving
this is where you put the real-time
business logics evaluation evaluator is
where you put the evaluation code so now
let's take a look at the architecture in
more details one thing that you can do
is one thing one of the many functions
of an engine is you want to train a
model and deploy it as a surface another
important function of an engine is it
will respond to user Curie and returned
predicted results and of course
evaluation but we're not going to go
through eval talk about evaluation today
just focus on the first two okay this is
how it would look like when you train a
model with your engine bay
on top of prediction IO platform the
event server will you call basically you
pull data from the event server from
your engines with the datasource
components which is a class that gives
you a family with the MVC of web
development is every component is
basically an independent class where you
can swap in and swap out and data pepper
ater and algorithms so data sauce take
the data from event server return a
training data components objects and it
will automatically be passed to the data
pepper ater data pepper a detective sin
and then do some processing and send the
final prepared data to all the algorithm
class that you have prepared and the
models will be built and they will be
stored and be persistence in memory in a
distributed Kuster so if you're planning
to play with spark if you plan if you're
doing spark you understand that setting
up a Custer and then you can have the
data handled by spark it might be in
memory it might be stored in the disk
space it's automatically handled by
spark so if you build the model with the
out DD formats then your model would be
load in a cluster it can be handled in
memory or it can be in this space so
it's automatically handled by spark
basically the great thing is you don't
need to write all this stuff by yourself
if you're using the platform now actual
code very quickly
free free main classes that you would
look at so everything I'm talking about
is open source so you can go to the
github and look at the template engine
template with all the source codes there
I'm just trying to give a high-level
view of the classes here so datasource
class comes with retraining function
this is where predict Pio train will be
called so when you want to train a model
you run the command line called Pio
Train
it will send it will trigger the
retraining of data source and you do all
kind of fancy stuff not so fancy
actually just read data from the event
server but if you have other data source
like streaming data email campaign data
mail teams you can pull all the data
into your engines at this class and when
the data training data objects is
returned it will trigger the P pair
function of pepper ater so here you can
do all the data preparation data
cleansing to me I think why is it useful
is because a lot of times we want to do
different type of data cleansing like
when when I was attending the kdd
competitions or things like that when
I'm trying out different algorithms I
always forget the part okay in this
iteration am I using this kind of
cleansing method or in that in that
iteration am I using another kind so
having a structure like that would make
it much easier for you to manage two
different components and so prepare
return prepared data to all the
algorithm class that you have defined to
the Train function of algorithm and this
is where you run the ML lib or Apache
mahout or your secrets algorithms
basically based on the prepare data now
you can prepare train the data prepare
the model and if you when you return the
model the model will be stored
automatically so later on you the system
will retrieve it to respond to
prediction Curie so now you have an
engine you can read data you have an
algorithm in it you train the model the
engine is running as a service on
production and in a really scalable way
the next thing you want to define in
your engine source code would be how do
you respond to that I mercury the
beautiful we show graph would be like
this the mobile application stand a
Curie that's like
for this user ID give me five products
so that's the Curie the curia will
trigger the algorithm class again but
this time another another function and
the model that you have built will be
loaded up automatically and make a
prediction and return predicted results
to serving layer serving layer will be
able to return the JSON format or JSON
data data in JSON format back to your
mobile application this is how you make
prediction and retrieve prediction
results in real-time and of course we
support more than one algorithms so this
is the design that we propose what
modern machine learning engine
developments should looks like the code
is simple let's say in your case as I
mentioned we're building a recommender
system so the CUNY format is user user
ID and number of products that we want
to recommend but if you're building
other type of machine learning tasks
like classifications or regressions you
might have different types of QE input
but let's just take this example the way
that you define this Curie is define a
class define variable in it define
another variable in it like user and the
number of products and make it
serializable by the way what programming
language I'm using Scala right you get a
t-shirt I think later on so good answer
and correct answer so prediction now is
built on Scala right now we support Java
we support Scala language scholars a
beautiful jvm language by the way we
have planned to support other
programming languages so it depends on
your usage if you're just using the
engine template as is you don't need to
touch the source code but we also give
you the flexibility to customize the
code like in Scala or in Java
so the same way we define a predicted
result class so so the predicted result
would be a list of items so the way we
define a class is basically an array and
the rate of items and the score that we
predict so now you have already defined
an input and output format of an engines
the platform will automatically convert
the JSON data input into the class and
create an object and same wise for the
return that result it will automatically
convert the objects to a JSON format and
return to your mobile app or your
website so it's quite simple here the
two classes that you touch is algorithm
and it's predict function now it's not
the Train function train function you
use it during formal training but for
responding to user Curie you use the
protective function of algorithms so
your mobile application santa Curie the
platform will pass it to predict along
with the model that you have built
pyrius Li it will load it up from spark
Kuster automatically to your function so
you can perform all kinds of fancy
processing most likely you just call
predict function to get like five
products and all algorithms that you
have defined it will pass the predicted
results as a sequence or as a list of
physical list to serve of serving class
this is where you would like to combine
the predicted result or you want to do
any kind of real-time processing of the
predicted results before you've returned
it to the mobile application so the
engine itself is defined by a factory so
it defines the name of data source
pepper rater algorithm and serving so
the cheating here is we called it das e
but D actually has two components data
separator data source and date
evaporator but if you can come up a
better name for this design pattern
let us know because we're always open
for new names so this is prediction IO
I just wanna introduce the high level of
way of building more reusable engines
because I believe that it's time for
companies or developers like us to move
beyond algorithms or just algorithm
modeling but actually apply algorithms
on production and when you want to build
something on production specific
business logics data source distributed
distributed service scalability is
really important and that's why we spend
a lot of time introducing developing
this architecture and it has been test
and used by hundreds of companies we're
quite happy contributors communities so
hopefully it's useful and one bonus
point of using this platform is it's
built on top of the latest open-source
technology so one line one command line
of installation of prediction IO you get
the whole stack of Apache spark xbase
for data storage and the MLE algorithms
libraries but of course you can
incorporate other algorithm libraries
into it so it if you if you're starting
out new is a great start and the
one-line combine is developed by our
co-worker David who is like at the back
there having a beer so it's a new young
community feedback is really welcome so
run the command line install prediction
IO is what you're going to do later if
you want to try it launch event server
with one command build an engine you
don't need to build an engine from
scratch you can download an engine
template like recommendation similar
product discovery you can download them
and just build it trainer trainer model
and deployed it if you want to update a
model with new data you just need to run
the Train and deploy it again everything
will be taken care of automatically so
this is the accurate
sure we love and we ambition more and
more companies will be using you're not
talking about one mobile application but
maybe your mobile application your
website your email campaign we have
media company using it for multiple
outlets like different type of Parros or
sending data into one event server
because the great way is you aggregate
all the data in the event server so you
can build different engines on it
recommendation is just the beginning but
there are a lot of things we would love
to do like classification of all these
score prediction and things like that so
on one single platform your data source
code can be reusable people can build on
top of it together as code of reusable
and scalable that's what we provide and
as a next step everything again is on
github and one one thing I asked for is
if you have any feedback let us know on
our Google group because we have been
building it for one and a half year it's
still very early so contribution if you
if you if you want to contribute to any
part of it we really welcome
contributors we have a hundred of
contributors around the world right now
but we really don't have enough
contributors on this project so your
participation is really welcomed thank
you
any questions very good question so the
question is about so the question is
about
now the model requires the mobile app to
send accurate to the engines and
retrieve prediction results and but how
about cases where we just want to push
the message to the mobile application
this is something we haven't developed
yet
but we do have use case of push
notification with one of the largest
media companies so basically they want
to push a message to users every day
that's different certain different times
one way you can do is to do a call like
every hour every half-hour to the
engines the great thing about it is the
call is really like the framework itself
is really lightweight and you can add
logics here to check ok it's not the
right time to pour so just return
nothing instead of calling the model
every time so it's an intermediate
solution not a perfect one but hopefully
it's off your problem in other great
questions so the question is what's the
performance we're not good in terms of
we didn't do any performance improvement
but we are great because we built on top
of the latest technology so out
performance it's just as good as Apache
spark just as good as HBase just as good
as the latest lightweight framework
responding to REST API so if you're
building on top of the architecture you
can't beat the performance of Apache
spark but I guess that's already the
latest performance that you can get in
terms of the JVM
the processing framework sorry what kind
of data size we're using so it's an open
source product we don't host your data I
think that's that's one thing we want to
I want to clarify as well
so you install prediction IO on premises
or you can launch a cloud service like
AWS and you can have a perfect cloud of
prediction of installation Custer and
you import your own data into prediction
IO so it's really up to you but related
to the performance question where as
fast as Bach
we're as scalable as xbase so we have
companies using it for like 50 notes
with no problem
so that's that's how scalable it is
thank you any other questions
very very easy so we have technically
speaking we have two types of algorithms
that we can support one is local
algorithm any JVM Java algorithms or
even our portable to Java algorithm we
can support with that interface another
type of algorithms we support is
anything that read LD d return LD d
basically the Spock standard you can
integrate in it we have like students
working on the project for fun and they
integrate the graph algorithm graphics
algorithm into the framework within a
few days so it's not extremely difficult
but if you need any support we're happy
to help as well so I guess I should
reserve time for another great speaker
and I'll pass the time to you to
introduce the speaker thank you
Thank You Simon